on va retrouver tout de suite monsieur
camara bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
moi je joue les monsieur monsieur camara
donc vous avez une entente avec la ville
de montréal le montant ses 347 1000 $ on
se rappelle de toute l'histoire vous
aviez été accusé à tort d'avoir agressé
un policier c'était en début 2021 au
départ la poursuite initiale c'était 1,2
million est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
satisfaits de cette entente
écoutez merci de mon amitié mais le plus
important pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
d'espoir
essayer de tourner la page
j'ai trouvé ma santé et me concentrer
beaucoup plus sur mes activités mon
travail et ma famille comme on le dit
souvent l'argent n'est jamais assez donc
l'essentiel pour moi ce qui est très
important pour moi c'est ma santé est
passé à autre chose comment vous allez
aujourd'hui monsieur camara
oui écoutez vous savez j'ai j'ai reçu
beaucoup de soutien les québécois
beaucoup de soutien n'est ce pas de ma
famille des amis donc j'essaye de se
monter tout ça et je vais mieux
aujourd'hui avez vous senti un soutien
de la population des gens qui ne vous
connaissais pas même mais qui ont été
révoltés par votre histoire et qui vous
voulez vous envoyer des messages de
soutien
tout à fait même en passant par les
réseaux sociaux il ya des gens qui qui
me contactent que je ne connais même pas
je reçois des colis de beaucoup de
personnes que j'ai jamais rencontré dans
un soutien vraiment général de toute la
population que j'apprécie bien et je
profite de votre antenne le remercie
de ce qui est de
qu'ils ont donnée sera apporté à moi et
à toute ma famille durant toute cette
période c'était vraiment traumatisant
n'importe qui à votre place que rêver
que ça aurait été complètement sous le
choc est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que vous portez encore cette histoire
tragique là ce que vous sentez vous avez
vous encore des images qui vous habite
comment on vivait sa ses souvenirs là
tout à fait c'est quand même difficile
de se voir tout le temps n'est ce pas en
ligne sur internet
mais ce qui est important aujourd'hui
pour moi c'est de comme je le dis de
passer à autre chose mais de pousser
n'est ce pas les uns les autres de
prendre leurs responsabilités pour le
pack e n'est ce pas c'est de telles
erreurs arrivent dans le futur ce qui
est très important parce que ça peut
ruiner déjà
avez vous confiance aujourd'hui envers
les policiers c'est quoi votre relation
comment on les voyait aujourd'hui n'est
pas ici
écoutez cette relation est quand même
difficile à rétablir mais je passe de
leur côté
je peux dire que c'est une grande leçon
quand même et puis que disons prendront
part les actions pour que cela n'arrive
pas donc je pense qu'ils ont pris aussi
des engagements à ce que l'image n'est
ce pas population policiers pour
piscines et spas se rétablir quand vous
êtes au volant par exemple il ya une
voiture auto patrouille dans le secteur
est ce que vous me sentais nerveux
oui évidemment évidemment c'est
que ce soit à montréal ou un peu partout
quand même parce que je vois
les batteries de police ça me ça me
fait n'est-ce pas revivre un peu au
cauchemar c'est compliqué ouais ouais
mais c'est ça en vivre avec un
traumatisme avec des séquelles c'est
quelque chose c'est long avant d'en
guérir est-ce que vous avez un espoir de
le retrouver une confiance de vraiment
tourner la page même dans les souvenirs
même dans ses réactions de nervosité est
ce que vous avez confiance que ça va
passer ça
c'est sûr que ça va être difficile mais
comme je vous ai dit
j'ai le soutien heureusement de
plusieurs personnes qui continuent de le
faire d'ailleurs donc je pense pouvoir
passer à travers tout ça et retrouver la
confiance c'est beaucoup plus importante
pour moi ce qui fait la différence dans
votre histoire qui a permis heureusement
de mettre fin à cette erreur judiciaire
et à vous sortir de là c'était ces
images d'une caméra des transports c'est
les policiers avaient eu à l'époque où
votre incident est arrivé une caméra
corporelle avez vous l'impression ça
aurait changé l'histoire que finalement
vous aurez jamais véhicules erreurs que
vous avez vécu
tout à fait c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
les gens se sont élevées pour demander à
ce que les policiers puissent avoir un
espoir des caméras corporelle ça aurait
certainement pu n'est ce pas éviter
cette erreur en tout cas d'arrivée
donc vous pensez qu effectivement vous
plaidez pour cinq américains corporelle
aujourd'hui tout à fait tout à fait
monsieur camara votre vie est le bouc
changé depuis un an il ya eu cet
événement tragique bouleversant mais
vous étiez dans l'anonymat maintenant
votre nom est connu vous avez obtenu une
résidence permanente canadienne vous
êtes un processus pour devenir un
citoyen et vous êtes père de famille de
jumeaux vous voyez l'avenir avec une
certaine confiance
tout à fait moi je suis je suis très
confiant dans l'avenir je suis
avec les bébés donc je sais que l'avenir
quand même beaucoup de choses
je suis je compte quand même profiter
pleinement avec avec les jumeaux à
québec écouter vraiment on souhaite
juste le meilleur maintenant pour vous
pour vos jeunes enfants pour votre
famille merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue ce très généreux de votre part
merci
merci beaucoup je lis au revoir au
revoir